and the yankees have two on and no one
out
and here is the american league player
of the week and richly deserved
aaron judge and a swing and a miss huge
strikeout for jordan a straight changeup
hit
on his hands an infrequently used pitch
that gets the job done for jordan lyles
that is a big strikeout and it brings up
gio urshayla
in a scoreless first inning for basic
they are sending mayhew the throw is not
in time
it's cut off it's an rbi single for
urchella
and the yankees lead one nothing you
know that's what we mean about george
shelling both john and i have been
talking about how great your shella
is just get it done you need if you need
just a lead it was a
little breaking pitch in the middle of
the play didn't do too much wasn't going
to get that one over the wall
just get it right in between those two
fielders and that's what he did and
that's what he does
56 strikeouts since he's had his last
walk
that is impressive i mean especially
this day and age and
coming off his best last wednesday in
tampa st
petersburg we saw it eight shutout
innings no walks
12 strikeouts and that wasn't a 10-1
game that was
a one to nothing shutout solac getting
270 seven homers 19 runs bad
swing and a miss he struck him out so
here's
nate lowe swing and a miss with that
strikeout
he has now tied a major league record
for the most strikeouts
without a walk so it'll be a 3-2 to
gallow he's struck him out swinging and
that's a new major league record
59 strikeouts without a walk for garrett
cole since april
the 12th or garrett cole to face garcia
dahl and connor falefa
in the ranger half of the second hit in
the air to right field
this is deep judge going back at the
wall it's history
adolesce garcia has tied the game with
an opposite field home run
[Applause]
his first at-bat ever against garrett
cole and he takes him deep
to tie it at one a lot of times you
don't know if an opposite field home run
is going to be going right off the bat
but garcia's got so much pop i don't
even know if he got full extension on
this but you know that
he's ready for the garrett cole
challenge got the fastball down the
middle good wood on it
watches that one fly eleven homers 28
rbis we're tied
six at bats against garrett cole the
rangers have two doubles and a home run
and they've got a chance to untie this
one one game here in the bottom of the
second
line drive left center base hit and the
rangers laid
david dahl is home digging for second
counter falefa here's the throw
not in time a hustling double and the
rangers have a two-to-one lead
it's double mania you got a hold of a
breaking pitch there i want to say a
slider toward the outside
part of the plate and got it well above
weighed the shortstop and i think izzy
was thinking two all the way
well they're getting some good swings
off garrett cole home running three
doubles
travino with a home run and six rvis
this year base head
up the middle counter scores easily
trevino delivers and it's three one
rangers
that's good to be home you know i think
a lot of people were wondering coming
into tonight's game
how are the rangers going to react how's
the offense going to fair
after struggling six games on the road
and i think a lot of people wonder with
garrett cole on the mound what's that
gonna look like
he now has five strikeouts and that
brings up joey gallo
and that's way inside and low ball four
well the pressure's off the ball gets
away
from higashiyoka joey races down to
first he falls down throw behind him
and he literally crawls back to the back
safely that's the most exciting walk
in baseball in years this won't be the
last
you hear about this from his teammates
you see this foot
let's catch the base coming over it the
other thing that walk did is that put
an end to a major league record long
streak
for this guy garrett cole he had not
walked a batter since
april 12th and here is higgy
who granted into a double play his first
time first pitch is grounded over third
diving stopped by culberson
gets up froze and he got him with a huge
stretch by low out toward right field
a dazzling play on both corners to
retire
higashiyoka culverson diving toward the
line scrambling to his feet
making a strong throw slightly offline
and nate lowe reaching
way out toward right kept his foot on
the bag and hauled it in
willie calhoun leaves things off he's
doubled over first and struck
out this will be the third time through
the ranger order against garrett cole
and a high drive hit well to center
field that goes gardner
to the track at the wall that ball is
history
just to the left of the 407
willie lamont calhoun with his fifth
home run of the year
and the rangers lead it four to one the
rangers have dropped the hammer on
garrett
cole tonight calhoun accents it with his
fifth homer of the year
and doing so with a little bit of a chip
on his shoulder you see him stand up on
that right after contact fastball down
the middle and willy knew he got it
around a walk to judge and there's a
dribbler hit out second base
it is so lacked the first and the sides
retired and jordan lyles for the second
time this year has gone six innings
lyles what a night for him quality start
six innings
a run on six hits one walk and six
strikeouts
trevino and rbi single in a strikeout
4-1 rangers leading in the sixth
and culverson running from first and now
coming in from third garcia
the throw gets away culverson will go to
third
successful hijinks indeed a double steal
subterfuge at its finest right there
just nuttiness on the bases rangers
add to their lead now have another
runner in third
go two-way and here is voight swung on
and hit in the air to deep left
that ball is high it is far it is
gone into the second deck boyd
hits one to detroit hey homers in the
yankees now trail
5-2 he led the majors with 22 home runs
last year and now he gets his first one
of this season and it's a poke
wow what a blast time for ian kennedy
this is his 17th game
20 strikeouts in 16 innings four walks
he's 10 for 10
and save opportunities and it's only
fair paul we've already talked about
phil hughes
now we've said ian kennedy we just have
to say the the name java
chamberlain and the yankees are down to
their final out and looks this one
into the air left field you can make it
over eight calhoun is there this one is
over
the rangers take the opener from new
york a
5-2 final and the 11th save of the year
for ian kennedy